you're working tues video playing card
start from hmm yeah this is one of the
Baltic countries estonia yeah I cannot
really tell them apart okay the news Oh
probably and should i go for the sameish
yeah come on it's always check always
interesting this is the very
old-fashioned approach back from the pod
Vinick kappa blanca game of course you
can improve on kappa blancas play it's
been quite a number of years still this
was played 1938 but the overall
structure is still considered to be
rather favorable for wide so much that
almost no one strong player would go for
this for the setup yeah White's ideas f3
Andy for black needs to pressurize the
center so that I'm not able to easily
expand like that yeah this is the worst
possible setup actually I can just play
a 34 now wow this is amazingly bad okay
I can just just take it so Bishop g5 and
night f4 Bishop g5 yeah it is good first
first they're pinning that
yes he far as so amazingly bad because
it concedes any sort of pressure on the
center it immediately if he if he
doesn't play a five here he gets run
over with III d5 and besides the fibers
hanging but this this now I can take
some I will just keep the depot and he's
awfully weak on the light squares
nida for rookie one he must even
consider to play g5 but ya didn't do
that okay yeah maybe you must play g5
the issue is the King position he will
have constant problems not with the king
and I've got always rookie five and
taking the f porn
check yeah I played the keep it simple
approach leading to a good end game
because it's got those big bones I'm
frightening King III jack yeah if I take
it I can just take it maybe this is even
better activating the rook on the
fifth-ranked yeah this is better
threatening rookie five yeah I can just
what should I take here actually
spurt good when h3 it will play g4
anyway but take a look drugged edge too
yeah this is this is easier
check
so Brooke a 70 mmm Group C 1 I can go
Kingda to maybe maybe I just play
forever
so looks you five now getting c4 check
yeah this is too connected passes
against the 28 points
chad is relatively easy to win check
check
King here and now I need to reroute the
look the king is now near enough to the
porn so the a bonus is not too dangerous
I can go Brooke f1 h 1 something like
that and then come from the back yeah
all this one so just I don't you got
here it's got the check hmm shouldn't do
that maybe just intensify
okay this didn't work check let's cut
the King on the edge on very hard to
believe that the shouldn't be chanting I
mean check check check yeah i know i can
run the pants check drawn push the pause
a 3 root k wanna dive I get it yeah now
the pulse when went on their own black
resigned yeah that's um
the problem with this c4 move I didn't
really get anything out that the problem
is simply it doesn't put any pressure on
the center here you can even think about
after em 396 maybe I even played this
too quickly with your form it leads to a
big edge but maybe I could have even
prepared this with a for Bishop a three
or something but this is just good even
if I've is a good move but okay I grab
this pawn Knight h3 is the computer
recommendation we are but this is just
good for white I mean no doubt about
that TI just transpose into this and
this clearly better and can the computer
is on plus three all the time so despite
the initial equal material why does
completely winning I'm not quite sure
that I played it in the best possible
way I think I always kept a big edge
check yeah this this really should win
the two connected passeth against the
double-a pawns with whites pieces being
coordinated okay thanks for watching